brighton beach au sud de brooklyn ce
quartier accueille les immigrés de toute
l'ex union soviétique
il est surnommé little odessa en
référence à la ville au bord de la mer
noire
nadia et ukrainienne elle dort seulement
trois heures par nuit inquiète pour sa
famille restée sur place en fait aux
faux
airs de 9
go
à little odessa très peu de russes
soutiennent la guerre je la dis me
régale il est originaire de moscou ils
ont fui ligne politique en 1981
dans la rue principale les commerces
affichent leur solidarité avec l'ukraine
dans cette vitrine est mannequin pour
des vêtements bleus et jaunes ici on
vend des drapeaux et des rubans fait
main et les journaux locaux compare même
petit à une pierre cette épicerie russe
a même changé son nom est effacé sa
référence à la russie un geste
symbolique pour les clients et les
employés ukrainiens comme suit lane à la
maison de sa belle soeur a été bombardée
la nuit ya
quasiment
dans la même rue myrha il dirige une
école d'échecs sera chaud cet ancien
champion a entraîné l'équipe nationale
soviétique irene il
présentera chaque année un certain
groupe de white a laissé
son élève ukrainien daniel coup par le
conflit un jeu d'échecs ne
sai
son musée
pour les habitants de little odessa
cette guerre est une bataille perdue
d'avancé